[Music]
in the 1950s scientists programmed a
first generation computer to learn using
the same rules as the human brain
he's using it to explore the mysterious
problem of how the brain learns
this model is called a neural network
it's made up of many basic units that
compute by taking inputs from other
units and passing them on as simple
calculations
the answers are recorded by designated
output units
pathways strengthen and the model learns
when many different inputs result in the
same output
today advanced versions of these models
called deep neural networks are the most
successful ai ever created
they power image and speech recognition
and recognize patterns in massive sets
of data making astonishing predictions
about the future
but there's a dark mystery here we have
no idea how deep neural networks work
what happens inside their billions of
hidden layers that allows them to
converge to a solution
now for the first time ever a group of
researchers has found a mathematical key
that might just open this black box
historically a lot of
methods
in machine learning
were designed to be to have simple
properties
where the the model designer kind of was
guaranteed
that they would obtain a certain
solution if they used a particular
algorithm or model deep neural networks
move away from that paradigm
the model designer chooses how many
units they would like to have in each
one of the hidden layers
that's referred to as the width of the
neural network
yasmine berry and her colleagues at
google's brain team hope to
mathematically simplify a deep neural
network by considering an extreme case
they took the network's width to be
infinite
one of the goals was just to understand
what happens in that limit
of infinitely wide deep neural networks
to see if we could say anything
concrete about it
incredibly they could
berry mathematically reduce those
infinite width networks to something
simpler called kernel machines
algorithms with a history going back to
the 19th century mathematician carl
friedrich gauss
it captures a richness that is similar
to a deep neural network in terms of its
functional dependence on the input
but it's more it's simpler than a deep
neural network because it's linear in
its parameters and even neural networks
in general are non-linear
kernel machines find patterns and data
by projecting the data into extremely
high dimensions
they map each point on a low dimensional
data set to a point in a higher
dimension
and then use the data points
characteristics to identify a class it
belongs to they do this classification
using a geometric object called a
hyperplane
kernel machines can compute infinite
dimensional data while staying firmly in
the realm of lower dimensional space
barry and her team were able to show
that kernel methods are mathematically
equivalent to an idealized version of a
deep net
the first major step to cracking open
the black box of deep learning
it's very rare to have
an exact equivalence between two things
in particular if that other thing
kind of is exactly solvable you can
write down the expressions
mathematically from my perspective
that's quite appealing
if this equivalence can be extended
beyond idealized neural networks it may
explain how practical deep neural
networks achieve their astonishing
results
to describe finite with networks you
know more work is needed but at least if
you have an exactly solvable model where
you have that full handle
you can then start to be systematic
about what's missing
and so for my mind that gives you a
starting point
there is a great debate happening in the
world of set theory
the study of collections of numbers and
other mathematical objects
it's about the nature of infinity or
rather
infinities the remarkable thing about
infinitives is that you know
they come in different sizes
take two infinite sets of numbers
if every number from one set can be
paired to a number from another the sets
are said to be bijective or the same
size
it's not the case that all all infinite
sets are bijected with each other that
there's a one-to-one correspondence
between them you have lots of examples
of sets such that one is strictly
smaller than the other
these questions about the sizes of
infinities go back nearly 150 years when
the german mathematician georg cantor
rocked the mathematical world by
discovering something that seems
counterintuitive
the infinite set of real numbers every
point on the number line outnumbers
natural numbers even though there are
infinitely many of both
in other words these infinities are not
equal the smaller one size or
cardinality was classified as aleph zero
and the next biggest size is aleph one
cantor conjectured that this aleph one
is exactly the size of the continuum of
real numbers in other words there are no
sizes of infinity between the sets of
natural and real numbers this came to be
known as the continuum hypothesis
but he could never prove it
the axioms or basic foundations of
mathematics simply didn't govern things
like cantor's infinity problem
but this year set theorist davide aspero
and his longtime collaborator ralph
schindler got closer to finding the
answer anyway we have the
right scenario in place about
uh 10 years ago and then but there's a
there was a missing ingredient and it
came quite you know just by
chance quite randomly
the breakthrough came when espero used a
technique to create a mathematical
object called a witness he used this
witness to verify that an extremely
powerful axiom martin's maximum plus
plus actually implies a rival axiom star
by unifying the two rival axioms aspero
and schindler showed that they are both
likely true implying that an extra size
of infinity actually does sit between
the sets of natural and real numbers
this would prove that there are more
reals than cantor had thought
finally bringing closure to the 150 year
old mystery and offering a coherent
alternative to the continuum hypothesis
but this is not even close to the end of
the story
newer and stronger axioms are already
challenging this result
and a battle is underway to decide which
side is right
the final chapter on the actual number
of real numbers the true size of the
continuum is yet to be written
this is a uvo field or at least an idea
of it
it's a wildly chaotic mathematical
surface where the height of every point
is chosen at random
forty years ago the theoretical
physicist alexander polyakov found a
striking use for these fields as a model
of quantum physics
polyakov intuited that they could do
this by unlocking the behavior of
theoretical objects called strings and
building a simplified model of quantum
gravity in two dimensions
it can be seen as a toy model for higher
dimensional cases but it can also be
seen as string theory because string
theory
in some sense it's about two-dimensional
surfaces
but polyakov's formula for understanding
the liuveo field stopped tantalizingly
short of being rigorous although he
attempted to explain it using a path
integral developed by richard feynman
the liuvil field resisted being
described in this way
around years 2013 we we started looking
at poliaco's path integral and according
to to what physicists were saying if we
could make sense of this path integral
we could directly construct in the
continuum uh quantum gravity so
we took the pattern table and we said
okay let's give it a shot we're going to
try to define it
vincent vargas and his colleagues set
out to precisely describe polycov's path
integral using a different approach
probability theory
they began by transforming the liuvil
field into a far milder object called a
gaussian free field it's kind of this
very rough landscape where there are
infinite spikes everywhere from the
point of view of physics the gaussian
field
is a boring theory it's it's it's
trivial theory where everything is
computable straight away and what we
realizing which came as a surprise i
think to the physics community that we
could express
anything that you naturally want to
compute on this theory
just in terms of something on the
gaussian physio
there were other leads to build on as
well in 1984 as a potential workaround
to his failed path integral polyakov
began trying to develop a technique
called the bootstrap
a mathematical ladder that gradually
builds up to a full complex
representation of a field
by chance two unrelated pairs of
physicists in the 1990s built on
polykov's bootstrap and managed to
completely solve the leuveo field they
called their formula d-o-z-z
even though it seemed to work it was a
miraculously lucky guess and they
couldn't prove it
this formula
which you know comes out of a
black box i mean it's it's black magic
uh
well it actually
has a probabilistic meaning and so what
we did
is show that our
path integral probabilistic construction
is equivalent
completely equivalent to this bootstrap
construction
[Music]
last year they unveiled a new and
improved version of polycov's path
integral defined in terms of the
gaussian free field
the work also explains the mysterious
origins of the doz formula
we're mapping probability theory to the
bootstrap if i were just talking on the
mathematical site we're mapping
probability through to representation
theory and with that they proved that
the liuvil field models quantum gravity
exactly as polycov thought it would 40
years ago
by bridging these two fields of math
which are really distinct i mean a
priori
and enables to
to to compute things that physicists
don't know how to compute
[Music]
you